es un nuevo récord para la industria
francesa de las bebidas el segundo
sector económico del país en términos de
exportaciones no solo se recuperó tras
la pandemia sino que superó las cifras
de los años anteriores al levantarse las
restricciones alrededor del mundo se
abrieron bares y restaurantes y las
ventas internacionales de vino francés
alcanzaron la suma de 15 mil 500
millones de euros en 2021 un aumento del
28 por ciento respecto al 2020 y del 11
por ciento en comparación con el 2019
además las exportaciones hacia eeuu se
vieron favorecidas por la retirada de
aranceles en marzo de 2021 que había
impuesto donald trump en 2019 en el
marco de una disputa sobre subsidios al
sector aeronáutico los envíos al mayor
mercado fuera de las fronteras francesas
subieron un 34% hasta superar los 4 mil
millones de euros un cuarto de las
ventas al exterior el 'break' si tampoco
sacia la sed de vino de origen francés a
su segundo cliente el reino unido donde
las cifras escalaron un 20 por ciento
las ventas en el tercer mercado china
crecieron un 57% en parte por el amor
por el coñac pero también por el colapso
de las importaciones de vino australiano
en medio de las tensiones entre ambos
países sin embargo la federación de vino
y bebidas alcohólicas francesas alertó
de que el panorama es poco alentador
para este año y el siguiente la vendimia
de 2021 fue de mínimos históricos- cayó
un 20% las heladas en primavera y las
tormentas en verano devastaron los
viñedos